while covet 19 cases are on the rise flu  activity is extremely low this winter  and experts believe there are several  reasons why and they all have to do with  covid those travel restrictions we're  all wearing masks we're keeping socially  distant  and another difference the flu is mainly  spread by children  and many of them are distance learning  and when you do go to school  children are wearing masks social  distancing  so i think the main reason is that  children  are not sharing this virus amongst  themselves  a record number of flu vaccines were  produced this season the centers for  disease control reports more than  half of all adults were vaccinated by  the end of 2020.